si paraît-il dans le fauteuil ou à vtt
ainsi le président nixon et j'y suis
resté par et il a souligné m
et tous plus longtemps que le président
nixon sur sa demande d'ailleurs vous
évoquez la santé du président 27 août je
vais vous montrer une photographie voyez
cet homme de 79 ans qui me sert la main
connaissez vous beaucoup d'hommes qui
auront bientôt 80 ans et qui ont cette
allure paraît solidité comme vous le
voyez il semble en excellente santé
nous n'avons parlé jusqu'à présent de sa
santé physique alors sur le plan mental
et intellectuel il est proprement étonne
il jongle avec les chiffres avec les
dates avec lennon avec les citations il
est incontestablement en pleine
possession de ses moyens
le président maurice tanguay les
dirigeants chinois vous ont ils fait
part de leurs craintes vis-à-vis de
l'union soviétique
il arrive souvent dans les conversations
ici que malgré des différences qui sont
évidentes qui tombe sous le sens on
évoque 268 on évoque des événements
prague
il est incontestable qu'il ya une
inquiétude il est incontestable aussi
qu'un les français des affaires
étrangères qui a l'occasion de
rencontrer souvent les dirigeants
soviétiques peut fournir à ses
interlocuteurs chinois ce que
j'appellerais des éléments
d'appréciation mais un point très
frappant c'est qu'à aucun moment on a
cherché au cours des entretiens je viens
d'avoir à établir une sorte de
contradiction entre notre volonté
d'avoir et de conserver des relations
amicales avec la chine d'une part et
d'autre part la volonté de détente
d'entente et de coopération avec
l'europe de l'est et avec l'urss en
particulier la position particulière de
la france et de l'europe occidentale
en voie d'unification sur le plan
économique et monétaire on tient
d'ailleurs beaucoup en chine au
développement de la coopération intra
européenne pour des raisons évidentes on
s'intéresse beaucoup à la constitution
d'une force de 250 millions d'européens
dépendante des grands blocs de ce qu'on
appelle ici les superpuissances
il est incontestable que la position
particulière de la france et de l'europe
est bien comprise avez vous l'impression
que les états unis d'amérique pourrait
remplacer la france comme interlocuteur
privilégié de la chine
je ne le crois pas du tout qu'il y ait
une détente des rapports américano
chinois c'est évident il ya encore un
grand obstacle et contrairement à ce
qu'on pense le premier obstacle
saleh pas formose un jour il se réglera
le problème de formose mais on fait
confiance au temps pour le régler la
patience est une vertu chinoise le grand
obstacle c'est encore indochine il faut
bien le dire